[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATHIEU CHARTIER:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Mathieu and this
is my colleague Calin.
And today, we're
going to be going
over what's new with the Android
Runtime on Android, also known
as ART.
So what is ART?
Well, ART is the software layer
in between the applications
and the operating system.
It provides mechanisms for
executing Java language
and call in applications.
To accomplish this,
ART does two things.
It executes Dex files, the
intermediate representation
of Android applications, through
a hybrid model consisting
of an interpretation,
just-in-time compilation,
and profile-based
ahead-of-time compilation.
ART also does memory management
for Android applications
through an automatic reclamation
through a garbage collector.
This is a concurrent
compacting garbage collector,
so that there's less jank
for your applications.
Now let's look at
how ART has changed
over the last few years.
Over the years, there have
been many improvements to ART.
In Nougat, we introduced a
profile-guided compilation
to improve application startup
time, reduce memory usage,
and reduce storage requirements.
Also in Nougat, we added a JIT,
much like Dalvik used to have.
This was done to remove the
need for optimizing apps.
That was kind of a big problem
during Android system updates.
And in Oreo, we added a new
concurrent compacting garbage
collector to reduce RAM
requirements, have less jank,
as well as accelerate
allocations.
As you can see
here on the slide,
this new garbage collector
enabled a new dump pointer
allocator that is
17 times faster
than the allocator in
Dalvik or in KitKat.
Now we talked about what
happened in the past,
but what's new in Android P?
First of all, there are
new compiler optimizations
that help accelerate the
performance of Kotlin code
in Android.
This is especially
important since Kotlin
is a first-class
programming language
for Android development.
Next up, we have memory
and storage optimizations
to help entry-level devices,
such as Android Go devices.
This is important to help
improve the performance
for the next billion users.
And finally, we
have cloud profiles.
Device collected profiles
from the just-in-time compiler
are uploaded and
aggregated in the cloud
to enable faster performance
directly after installation
of applications.
So let's start with Kotlin.
Last year, we
announced Kotlin as
a first-class
officially-supported
programming language
for Android development.
And then, we began to
investigate the performance.
Why Kotlin, you might ask?
Well, Kotlin is a safe,
expressive, concise,
object-oriented language
that is designed
to be interoperable
with Java language.
The reason ART focuses
on optimizing Kotlin
so that the developers can
leverage all of these language
features while still having
fast and jank-free applications.
Let's see how Kotlin
optimizations are normally
performed inside of
the Android Runtime.
Usually, optimizations
are performed
in an investigative manner.
And there's an
order of preference
for fixing performance issues
so that the most amount
of Kotlin applications
can actually
benefit from the optimization.
The preferred option is
fixing a performance issue
inside of kotlinc.
And kotlinc is the compiler
developed by JetBrains Google
and JetBrains of course,
work closely together
on all kinds of optimizations
and fixes for issues.
If we fix a
performance issue here,
it'll be able to be
deployed to the most
amount of Kotlin applications.
Alternatively, if
that doesn't work,
then we consider fixing
the performance issue
inside of bytecode converters.
Fixing in the bytecode
converter will
enable existing versions
of the Android platform
to get the performance fix.
And if that option doesn't
work, the last option
is to fix the performance issue
in the Android Runtime, also
known as ART.
So the reason that we might not
want to fix in ART right away
is because ART is updated as
part of the Android platform.
So that means that not all
devices will get the fix.
Now let's look at an example.
One example of a
Kotlin optimization
is the parameter null-check.
As you can see here,
this is a simple method
that just returns the
length of a string,
but the string is nullable.
So what this means is that the
compiler inserts a null-check
into the function bytecode
to actually verify
that the string is
not null, and throw
the corresponding
exception if required.
Implemented in the
bytecode, the first step
is loading the name
of the parameter
and then invoking
a separate function
to do the actual null check.
So there is some
extra overhead here
as you might see, because the
invocation in the common case,
you do the extra indication
that goes to the function
to do the null check.
And this function in
turns, if required,
calls the third function to
throw the actual parameter is
null exception.
Checks such as
these are commonly
required for Java
language and Kotlin
interoperability because
Java language does not
have a non-nullable property.
Now let's see how we
can optimize this.
If we look at the bytecode, one
of the first things we can do
is actually inline the method
that does the null-check
into the caller.
After inlining, this
improves performance
because there is
one less invocation.
And from here, you can
see one other thing
we can do is that the
name of the parameter
is not actually required
unless the argument is null.
So from here, we
can do code syncing
to move loading of the parameter
name inside of the conditional.
So overall, these
two optimizations
help performance by removing
one invocation and one
of the loadings of
a string literal.
Apart from this optimization,
we also track Kotlin performance
on various benchmarks.
Other improvements here include
improved auto vectorization
of loops, also intrinsic
methods that are specifically
tailored for Kotlin code to
help improve performance there.
So the ART team
is always working
on improving this performance.
Now that we've done Kotlin,
what about memory and storage
improvements?
So since ART is responsible
for Java language and Kotlin
applications, it's
also pretty important
to just kind of make sure
that the programs don't
use too much memory and take
too much space on a device.
There have been several
improvements focusing
on this area, including reducing
the amount of space and memory
usage required by Dex files.
Now why are RAM and storage
optimizations important?
Well, recall that last
year, we introduced
a new initiative
called Android Go,
aiming at running the
latest versions of Android
on entry-level devices.
Since these devices typically
have 1 gigabyte or less
of RAM and 8 gigabytes
or less of storage,
it's kind of important to
focus on optimizing these areas
so that the users can
run enough applications
and install as many
applications as they--
or more applications than they
would otherwise be able to.
Now this isn't just
for Android Go.
Premium devices also benefit
from optimizations in these two
areas, but since they
have more resources,
normally it's to
a lesser degree.
Anyways, before we talk about
RAM and storage optimizations,
let's do a little bit of a
review about how applications
work on your Android devices.
An application normally comes
in an Application Package Kit,
also known as an APK.
Inside of the APK,
there are usually
one or more Dalvik Executable
Files, also known as Dex files,
that contain instructions that
ART uses to either interpret
or compile your application.
Since Dex files are required
to be quickly accessed
during execution, they are
mapped directly into memory
during application startup so
that ART can have quick access.
This means that there is a
startup cost as well as a RAM
cost proportional to the
size of the Dex file.
Finally, Dex files are usually
stored twice on the device.
The first place they
are stored is inside
of the application package kit.
And then the second
place they are
stored is in an extracted form,
so that ART can have faster
access during application
startup without needing
to extract from the
ZIP file each time.
Now let's take a closer look
at the contents of Dex files.
Within a Dex file, there
are several sections
containing different
types of data
related to the applications.
But where is the space
going in the Dex file?
One way to do this
is you can kind of
calculate where the space
is going for each Dex file
and average out the results.
This chart here is for the top
99 most downloaded applications
in the Play Store.
And you can see that the
largest section is the code item
section containing the Dex
instructions used by ART.
The next largest section
is the StringData section.
And this section contains
the string literals
loaded from code, method names,
class names, and field names.
Combined, these two sections
are around 64% of the Dex file,
so they're pretty important
areas to optimize.
Let's see if there's
a way we can reduce
the size of these sections.
One new feature introduced in
Android P is called CompactDex.
The goal of
CompactDex is simple--
reduce the size of Dex files
to get memory and store savings
on the device.
From the previous slide,
we saw that some sections
are larger than others.
So it's important to just
focus on the large sections
to get the most savings.
For the code items, they
are more often deduplicated.
And they also have
their headers shrunk
to save a space for each
method, essentially, inside
of the application.
And another thing here worth
noting about the string data
is that large
applications frequently
shift multiple Dex files in
their APK because of Dex format
limitations.
Specifically, the
64k method limit
means that you can only have
64,000 method references
in a single Dex
file before needing
to add another one
to your application.
And every time you add
another Dex file, this causes
duplication, specifically
of string data, that could
otherwise be stored only once.
CompactDex shrinks this
by providing deduplication
across the Dex files in the APK.
Now let's go to the
generation process.
First, let's look
at how Dex files
are processed on Android Oreo.
The first step run by Dex AOT--
the Ahead-Of-Time compiler--
is that the Dex files are
extracted from the APK
and stored in a VDex container.
The reason they are extracted,
as I mentioned earlier,
is so that they can be
loaded more efficiently
during application startup.
One other thing here worth
noting is the profile.
So the profile, as
introduced in Nougat,
is essentially data about the
application execution including
which methods are
executed during startup,
what methods are hot-- so
compiled by the JIT compiler--
and what classes are loaded.
On Oreo, we are already
optimizing the Dex files
stored in the VDex container by
applying layout optimizations.
And also we were
deciding which methods
to compile based on what
methods are hot in the Dex file.
Now let's look at Dex processing
on Android P. In Android P,
the ahead-of-time compiler
now converts the Dex files
to a more efficient
CompactDex representation
inside of the container.
One new addition here
is the introduction
of a shared data section.
Specifically, data that is
present in multiple Dex files
will be in the
shared data section
only once, so it
kind of deduplicates
data that's commonly shared.
And one of the most
commonly shared
things here is the StringData.
So this is how we reduce
the large StringData
section that we saw earlier.
Finally, since the conversion
is automatically done on-device,
this means that all
existing applications
can get the benefits
of CompactDex
without needing to
recompile their APKs.
OK, so let's look at one
example of how we actually
shrink the Dex code items.
Apart from the
instructions, each code item
has a 16-byte header.
And then most of the
values in the header
are usually small values.
So what we do here is we
shrink the fields in the header
to be 4 bytes each.
And then we have an
optional pre-header
to extend them as required.
The pre-header is 0 bytes
in most of the cases,
but can be up to 12
bytes in the worst case.
So other than the
pre-header, we also
shrink the instruction count.
Since the average method is
not going to be that large,
we shrink this down to 11
bytes instead of 32 bytes,
and we use the 5
remaining bytes for flags
that are ART specific.
Finally, we moved
the debug information
into a separate
space-efficient table
to help enable more
deduplication of the code
items.
Overall, this optimization saves
around 12 bytes per code item
in the CompactDex file.
And here are the results for
the top 99 most downloaded APKs.
So the average space required
by the Dex files on a device
is around 11.6% smaller.
And then other than
the storage savings,
you also get memory savings
because the Dex files
are resident in memory
during application usage--
at least partially
resident in memory.
And one more thing here.
Let's go over the layout
optimizations a little bit.
So even though we had introduced
the JIT profiles in Android N,
we did not have any layout
optimizations back then.
So what this means is the Dex
is kind of randomly ordered
and not disregarding
the usage pattern.
In Android O, we added this
type of layout optimization
that groups the methods used
during application startup
together and the
methods that are hot--
so that means their code
is frequently accessed
during execution-- together.
This seems like a
pretty good ad--
a pretty big win so far.
Well, let's see what we did
for Android P. In Android P,
we have more flexible
profile information,
which enables us to put the
methods that are used only
during startup together.
This helps reduce
the amount of memory
used because the application
or the operating system
can remove those pages
from memory after startup.
We also put the
hot code together,
since it's frequently
accessed during execution.
And finally, we put the code
that's just never touched
at all during
execution at the end,
so that it's not loaded
into memory unless required.
And the reason that these layout
optimizations are important
is because they improve
locality and reduce
how many parts of the
Dex file are actually
loaded into memory during
application usage and startup.
So if you improve
the locality here,
you can get startup benefits
and reduction in memory usage.
And now to Calin
for cloud profiles.
[APPLAUSE]
CALIN JURAVLE:
Thank you, Mathieu.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Calin.
And I'm here today
to present to you
how we plan to improve and
scale up the Android Runtime
profiling infrastructure.
However, before we
start, profiling
is a rather overloaded term.
When we speak about profiling
in today's presentation,
we're going to refer
to the metadata
that Android Runtime captures
about the application
execution, metadata
that is going
to be feed into a profile-guided
optimization process.
We're going to see how we extend
the on-device capabilities
in order to drive performance
right at install time.
Before we jump into what is
new and how actually it works,
let me briefly remind
you how Android uses
profile-guided optimizations.
This is an efficient technique
that we introduced an Android
Nougat as part of a
hybrid execution model.
Hybrid means that the
code being executed
can be in three
different optimization
states at the same time.
The primary goal
of this technique
is to improve all key metrics
of the application performance.
We're talking about faster
application startup time,
reduced memory footprint,
a better user experience
by providing less
jank during usage,
less disk space used by
the compiler artifacts--
which means more disk
space for our users--
and nonetheless, an
increased battery life,
because we do
heavy optimizations
when the device is not used
rather than at the use time.
How does this work?
It all starts when the Play
Store installs the application.
But first, we do very,
very light optimizations
and we have the application
ready to go for the user.
At first launch,
the application will
start in what we call
an interpretation mode.
As the runtime executes
the application code,
it discovers the most
frequently used methods
and the most important
methods to be optimized.
That's when a JIT
system kicks in,
and it'll optimize that code.
During this time,
the JIT system also
records what we call
profile information.
This profile information
essentially encapsulates data
about the methods that
are being executed
and about the classes
that are being loaded.
Every now and then, we
dump this profile to disk
so that we can reuse it later.
Once the device is put
aside and it's not in use--
a state which we call
idle maintenance mode--
we're going to use
that profile to drive
profile-guided optimizations.
The result is an optimized
app which will eventually
replace the original state.
Now when the user
relaunches the app,
it will have a much snappier
startup time, a much better
steady-state
performance execution,
and overall, the
battery will drain less.
In this state, the
application will
be interpreted, just-in-time
compiled, or pre-optimized.
Now just how efficient
is this technique?
We gathered some
data from the field
for Google Maps application.
Here we can see two charts.
The left one presents data
from a Marshmallow build.
You can see that
the startup time
is pretty constant over time.
It does not fluctuate.
And this is pretty
much expected.
You don't want to
have deviations here.
However on the
right-hand side, you
can see that in Nougat, the
startup time drops over time.
Eventually, it stabilizes
over being about 25%
faster than it used
to be at install time.
And this is great news.
It means that the more
the user uses the app,
the more we can optimize it.
And over time, the performance
gets better and better.
This is great, but
we can do better
and we want to do better.
We shouldn't need to wait
for optimal performance.
And our goal with
cloud profiles is
to deliver near optimal
performance for right
after install time,
without having
to wait for the
application to be profiled.
So let's see how this
is going to work.
Let me introduce you the
idea of cloud profiles.
This is based on main
two key observations.
First one is that usually apps
have many commonly used code
paths that are shared between a
multitude of users and devices.
Take, for example, classes
loading during startup time.
Each device will have
its own specific set.
However, globally, we can
extract the common intersection
of all those classes.
And that's valuable data
for us to optimize upon.
Second, we know that most app
developers roll out their apps
incrementally, starting
with alpha/beta
channels or, for example,
1%, 2% of their user base.
And the idea behind
cloud profiles
is to use this initial set
of alpha/beta channel users
to bootstrap performance
for the rest of the users.
So how's it going to work?
Once we have an
initial set of devices,
we're going to
extract the profile
information about your
APK from those devices.
We're going to upload
that information to Play.
And there, we're going
to combine everything.
We're going to aggregate
whatever comes in
and we're going to generate
what we call a core application
profile.
This core profile will
contain information
that's relevant
across all device
executions, and not
just a single one.
When a new device requests
for that application
to be installed, we're going
to deliver this core profile
alongside the main
application APK to the device.
Locally, the device
will be able to use
that data to perform
profile-guided optimizations
right at install time.
That will deliver an
improved code startup
performance and much better
steady-state performance
over time.
Now having profiles in the cloud
offers much more opportunities
than directly influencing
the app performance
with profile-guided
optimizations.
The core profiles offers
valuable data, for example,
for developers to act upon.
And we believe there
is enough information
there so that developers can
tune their own applications.
We're going to explore how we
can share these data later.
Now you can see in this workflow
that to deliver such a thing,
we need support from Android
platform and Play alike.
In today's presentation,
we're going
to focus on the Android support.
So what did we do in P to
support this lifecycle?
We added new
interfaces that will
allow us to extract the
profile and bootstrap
the information from the cloud.
The functionality is available
to all system-level apps which
acquire the necessary
permissions.
And in our case, Play
is just a consumer.
The two APIs I'm talking
about are profile extractions.
And these are exposed via
a new platform manager.
We call it ART manager.
The second API is
profile installation.
And this is seemingly integrated
in the current installer
session.
What we did here is to add a new
kind of installation artifact
that the platform understands.
We called this Dex
Metadata files.
Essentially, in a
similar way to the APKs,
the Dex Metadata
files are archives
which will contain information
in how the runtime can optimize
the application.
Initially, these
Dex Metadata files
will contain the core profile
that I mentioned about earlier.
At install time, they
will deliver these files,
if they are available,
to the device,
where they will be streamlined
into the Dex optimizer
on device.
It is worthwhile mentioning that
we'll offer support for Google
Play dynamic delivery.
So if you plan to
split the functionality
of your application
in different APKs,
all the APKs will have
their Dex Metadata files.
So let's take a look how
everything fits together
from the device perspective.
You remember that I presented
this diagram in the beginning,
showing how the
profiling works locally.
Let's focus here
just on the profile
file on the application.
Once we manage to
capture a profile file,
we're going upstream
this information to Play.
On Play, as I mentioned,
we'll aggregate this data
with many, many other profiles.
And when we have
a core profiles,
we're going to deliver it to
our new users as a core profile.
The idea of the
core profile is not
to replace on-device
profiling, it's
only to bootstrap the
profile optimizations.
So essentially
instead of starting
with a completely blank
state about your application,
we already know what are
the most commonly executed
code paths, and we'll
be able to start
the optimizations from there.
So now essentially what was a
pure on-device profile feedback
loop, it gets extended
with a cloud component.
Now I keep talking
about this core profile,
and I think it's
important to dedicate
a bit more attention to it.
So let's talk a bit how
we're going to build it.
We already know that
on-device, from one execution
to the other, the profiles
aggregate quite well.
They reach a stable
point pretty fast.
That means that it will not
reoptimize the application
over and over and over again.
After a few optimization
steps, it will stop.
However, that's data
from one device.
How well does this work when
you try to do it across devices?
How many samples you
would need in order
to get to a robust,
reliable profile?
We looked at our own
Google applications
and we tried to figure that out.
Here we can see a
plot which represents
the amount of information
in the core profiles
relative to the total
number of aggregations.
The y-axis represents the
amount of information.
And the actual value--
numeric value--
is not important there.
What is important
from this graph
is that actually
from 20, 40 kind
of number of profile
aggregations, the information
in the profile
reaches a plateau.
And that's very important.
It sends a very
important message.
It means that the
alpha/beta channel
users will provide
us with enough data
to build a core profile.
And it means that the
majority of the production
users of your application
will always have
the best possible experience.
So how do we actually
aggregate the information?
I mentioned before
that in the profile,
you will find information
about classes and methods.
On-device, this is
roughly how it looks like.
We're going to take all the
executions that we have seen
before, then we'll create
a union of everything
that we've seen.
In the aggregated
profile, you'll
have information about classes,
methods, about everything
that you've seen.
On cloud however, we don't
really want everything.
We only want the
commonly-executed code paths.
And what we are doing
instead of having a union,
we'll be having a
smart intersection.
We'll be only keeping
the information
relevant to all
executions, meaning
we're going to filter
out all the outliers.
The result is what we call the
core profile, which only keeps
the most commonly-seen samples.
And this is what's going to
get eventually to the device.
How well does this work?
Let's look again at data
captured from Google Apps.
We tested this across a
variety of applications.
And here are the results of
some representative ones.
In this set, you
can find application
which relies on native code--
for example, Google Camera--
or applications which are
much more Java oriented--
say, Google Maps or Google Docs.
For Google Camera,
for example, we
get a startup time
improvement of about 12.6%.
And that's excellent given that
the application itself doesn't
have a lot of Java code.
However, for Maps or Docs,
which are heavily Java-based,
we can see that the
optimizations improves
the startup time by
about 28% or 33%.
Across the board, we can
see an average of about 20%
improvement.
And that obviously
depends with what
the application is doing, how
my Java code is being used,
and so on.
Now I mentioned in the
beginning that besides improving
the application
performance directly
via profile-guided
optimizations,
the profile also offer
much more opportunities.
I'm going to present
a short use case study
and walk you through
some important aspects
that the profiles can reveal
about your application.
During this use case
study, I'm going
to focus on a single question--
are you shipping unnecessary
code to the clients?
Are you?
Let's take a look at some data.
Again, this case study reflects
the state of some Google Apps
that we tested.
We see that on average, we
profiled about 14% to 15%
of the code.
And about 85% of the
code remains unprofiled.
When you spread
the distribution,
we can see, for example,
that in some apps, 5% to 10%
of the code gets profiled.
In some other apps, even 50%
And this is a rather intriguing
result. And the reason for that
is that if the code is not
profiled, that most likely
means that it might not
have ever been executed.
Obviously, that's
for a good case.
I mean, the code for example,
can be unexpected error code
paths, right?
We all want the applications
to be reliable and robust,
and the error handling
must be there.
Hopefully, it never
gets executed.
You may have backwards
compatibility code,
support for previous
API level and such.
You may have features which
are not used on all devices.
It may have features
very targeted.
And you might also have a lot of
unnecessary code lying around,
maybe including libraries
that you don't really use.
Now it's a bit hard to
break down the percentage
for these categories.
And there can be other reasons
why we didn't profile the code.
But the skewed distribution
here is a strong indication
that there is a lot of room
of improvements for APK.
The code can be
reorganized or trimmed down
for better efficiency.
For example, Google Play
introduced dynamic delivery
schemes, which may
help you reduce
the code that you share
by targeting features only
to certain users.
And that's something
that you might
want to look at and
take advantage of.
So we believe that there is
quite a bit of unnecessary code
lying around, at
least in our own APKs.
Now since we've focused on
the code that actually doesn't
get profiled, is there anything
that we can extract out
of the profile code?
To understand this,
let me talk a bit
about different categories
of profile code.
When the application
code is being profiled,
the runtime will try to label
it depending on its state.
And you will have a label
for the startup category,
for the post-startup category,
and for the hot category.
Obviously, these are
pretty self-explanatory.
The hot category of
the code is essentially
what the runtime's seen to
be the most important part
of your code.
It's important to keep in mind
that these are not disjoint.
Say for example, that the
method foo is being executed.
This can be executing
during startup,
it can be executing
during post-startup time,
and it can also
be marked as hot--
for example, if you have
a very heavy computation
during that method.
Now if you know the code which
is executing during startup
time, if you focus
on that, you will
be able to lower the startup
time of the application.
As such, the first
impression that the users
will have upon your
application will be very good.
If you look at the
post-startup code,
that will help you, for example,
lay out the application Dex
bytecode.
That will lead to
memory improvements
and will be much smoother
on low-end devices.
As for the hot code,
this is the code
that should get
the most attention
for your optimizations efforts.
It's the code that is
most heavily optimized
by the runtime, and it might
be so because the runtime
identified that it would be
very beneficial to invest time
there.
And it's what if you,
for example, start with--
try to improve the quality and
the performance of your app,
this is where you should
spend your effort,
or your initial effort.
Now for this is
important, like how much
code of your application is
actually being marked as hot?
Because if everything
gets hot, then everything
can be optimized.
So that's not really useful.
Let me show you the breakdown
of these three categories.
In this graph, you can
see on the red columns,
the percentages for the profile
code and the not-profile code.
This will sum up to 100% and
it's what I showed you earlier.
They are here just
for the reference.
The blue boxes show
the percentages
of the startup code,
the post-startup code,
and the hot one relative
to the total Dex bytecode,
so don't expect it to add 100%.
Also, one piece of code can
be in different categories
at the same time.
But as you can see
here, the average--
on average about 10% of the
application Dex bytecode
is being marked as hot.
And this indicates that
when you focus on your app
optimizations, you can
dedicate the attention starting
with just a small part of
your application code base.
You obviously should spend time
on all the other parts as well,
but probably this is where
you should start from.
Let me go over a quick
review of what we presented
today and the main benefits.
We started with Kotlin,
and we described
a few new compiler optimizations
that we added that focused
on Kotlin performance.
We described briefly how we
approach Kotlin optimizations,
and that we first try
to seek improvements
in the Kotlin compiler.
We moved to memory and
storage optimizations,
and my colleague
Mathieu introduced you
to the concept of CompactDex.
This is a new Dex format
available just on-device, which
focuses on the memory savings.
And finally, I presented you
the idea of cloud profiles.
And we talk about
how we can bootstrap
the profile-guided
optimizations using
a small percentage of
alpha/beta channel users
in order to lead important
performance improvement right
after install time for the
majority of the production
users.
With this, I'd like to
thank you for your attention
and for your presence.
And I want to invite you all
to Android Runtime office
hours tomorrow, where we can
answer any questions that you
would have about
today's presentation
or about the runtime in general.
We're going to be at 5:30 in
section A. Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]